Is marriage really a good thing? I
guess it depends on the person, but I
think it's good. What does
marriage look like? Well,
for example, your wife always
smells good. It smells good. It
smells great. This is amazing.  Well,
when I go for a walk at night, I end
up standing on the leeward side, and then I
smell a sweet scent that makes me feel like I'm in a flower field, and I wonder if I'm going to die.Maybe
it's too early for me to say that.
Oh
yeah, Nakiru-san, did you know that
girls
buy cookies based on the design of the box? That's
stupid. I was surprised at first, too. The design is the deciding factor in a cookie, is
n't it? I was surprised at first, too. What's
important in food?  I wonder if it's not just the taste,
but my wife says that the taste is
important, but the cuteness of the packaging is also important.If you're so particular about the
packaging in the first place, you should also be particular about the
taste.Also, if it looks
cute, then when you pick it up.  You'll
get excited, right?
Well, there may be a point in that.If I were to
buy a car because I admire rotary engines, it would
be the same as if I wanted to buy an RX7.Girls buy boxes of cookies, which is very
educational.  Well then, do you know this?
Girls tend to
buy water at room temperature.So,
isn't that lukewarm water?Isn't the drink
cold?But
that's not the case.My wife says, ``Itsukasa-chan, it's finally
time.''  If you drink all that cold
food, you'll get cold.You
see, girls are
careful not to cool their bodies by drinking lukewarm water.I don't dare, I
understand.Is that so
?
Girls seem to have a lot of depth.
Well, the
best thing about getting married is that the world has expanded. By
living together, I discover
new things every day that I didn't know before.
Places I didn't care about,
feelings I didn't know about, people I couldn't meet,
all of these things, I feel like my possibilities have
expanded and
the world has expanded
[Music]